we got three animals right here man we
just want to let you know what how would
you how would you handle these three
situations here's the first one right
here
bryce famous put a deer in the twister
here's a fella right here has he been
shot
no
i would this guy's just trying to i
guess touch hands first
oh [ __ ]
damn
damn dude
so i guess he maybe got a little close
to petting him or something
how if you're if you're yeah how do you
handle that situation
whose side are you on there
first off he [ __ ] up he's right in
front of it you want to walk up behind
it yeah yeah that's where you [ __ ] up
yeah yeah come up behind it i take a
neon belly yeah um
you know don't give up position
that's all i got to say bro like like
straight up like stay on top when you're
talking with them deer bro cause they
got that they got that good top game
their bottom game is weak right you know
what i'm saying it becomes a positional
battle like i said he should have
approached from the back
that's where he [ __ ] but their bottom
game if you're on bottom there you got
those antlers that's insane to deal with
well that was a buck yeah that's that's
a different story right there but here's
what i would have done
out of uh you know locked out my arms
uh-huh and i got a little knee on the
ribs arms locked out and now he's awake
yeah
and then i'm just gonna brainstorm for a
minute
i'll be honest with you i ain't been
there today i ain't been in that one yet
i'm going to lock them out and i'm going
to brainstorm
a little bit bro that [ __ ] uh let me
tell you what that rear neck is going to
be hard with the antlers in the way yeah
you might have to pull triangle yeah you
know what i'm saying like it it's going
to get desperate uh yeah actually trying
at least you'd have more control you'd
probably be able to keep him upright
enough to keep that keep the antlers
away from you if you want to be real
[ __ ] up and you can talk about some
animal cruelty yeah um
you go for armbar
bro then then you won because even if
yeah he ain't going nowhere bro like if
them antlers are in the way bro go pull
armbar like i said i'm all about
position staying on top but if you can't
sink in that choke and that deer is
getting up and you see a arm go for that
arm bar brother yeah and he got four
arms dude that's what i'm saying bro
like he ain't gonna you know he ain't
got no defense you know the best
defenses hold your hands together yeah
what's he gonna do yeah
damn that's a risky move here's the
second one we got three of them for you
here's the second one now this lady got
walmart
that's a good position keep the volume
off
so that lady got she got uh
that lady got took it took that that's a
looks like a doe or just a female oh
yeah she just she took his back and got
him down see what you see here is
perfect we got situational awareness i
promise you this ain't her first go
around yeah you see that then hips on
that she's putting them hips on that
deer's hips she's keeping that low
center base knees spread out
i can tell you right now this ain't her
first first rodeo yeah this ain't the
first deer at the walmart for this lady
no bro and she's holding that arm she's
got that arm locked too if you see that
by that she's got she's keeping that arm
that deer from getting any uh i'm not
even gonna comment on this because she's
doing far better than i would have you
know what i'm saying like she that's a
clean up on all three she's gonna take
it out and it's done
i think yeah she's already cleaned up
let's get that third one the last one we
got here perfect technique
and this one we can have some audio on
oh no yeah this was fine
and how do you handle this situation
[Music]
oh yeah
well right there i don't see anybody
trying to cut off the the room you know
what i'm saying i see that guy first off
he gets up out of the chair and he's not
in his stance that's where he [ __ ] up
first yeah that's the first thing i do
because you know there ain't no that
door ain't he ain't gonna go out the
back door you know
first thing i'm doing see he's right out
the front door like i said because look
he ain't even got a stance
first i'm getting low in that stance
yeah i'm going left right you know he's
gonna have to go back to that door yeah
and then i'm gonna creep a little bit
yeah yeah yeah yeah
we're gonna get in range you know he's
gonna be doing this [ __ ] so
back up
you have no footwork there you go how is
he going to pursue that deer you know
what i'm saying he's flat standing
straight up he's completely unprepared i
wish that girl from walmart was there oh
yeah you really do
that's he was getting her hair cut
people completely unexpecting this [ __ ]
bro like they got to be ready you got to
be ready at all times but that's true
man i think you have to take a little
bit of position there for sure i think
that guy didn't want the smoke he kind
of wan he like kind of wandered over
there
he ain't never had some good deer jerky
yeah he never had he had some good deer
jerk he'd be like all right
i'm gonna cook you up
we're not letting this thing leave
that's right
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you